justin trudeau a de nouveau dénoncé
l'invasion illégale at il dit de
l'ukraine par la russie et monsieur
trudeau a dit que vladimir poutine avait
commis des crimes étaient responsables
de crimes de guerre odieux et qui sera
tenu responsable qu'il devra rendre des
comptes
et en ce jour or ce 8 mai jour de
commémoration de la capitulation de
l'allemagne nazie en 1945 il a tenu à
dire ceci dit mi-août il est en train de
faire honte à la mémoire au million de
russes qui ont lutté on fait des
sacrifices pour
vaincre de fâcher c'est pour assurer la
liberté alors le canada va fournir à
nouveau soutien militaire à l'ukraine y
compris des drones avec caméra et des
technologies d'image satellite et quand
on a demandé à volodimir zelensky si le
canada en faisait suffisamment pour
aider l'ukraine il a répondu qu'il y
avait trois pays les républiques baltes
acquise ukraine ne vais rien demandé de
plus parce qu'elle avait déjà tout donné
et il a dit que le canada c'était la
même chose pour le canada
jusqu'à
il ya un
cadeau
pour moi surtout soucieuse bros et moins
d'état l'ayant premier ministre
un peu plus tôt justin trudeau a pu
constater la dévastation causée par
l'armée russe dans la ville libérée dire
pin
mais c'est là qu'il s'est rendu tout de
suite en arrivant donc ir pin et social
est à bout de chat donc des villes ou
qui ont été occupées par les forces
russes et où les forces russes sont
accusées d'avoir commis des massacres on
parle de d'exécution de viols de
tortures
juste un truc doit donc pu voir par lui
même un peu la destruction et l'horreur
la brutalité de cette guerre et ce qui
l'a frappé c'est la résilience c'est la
détermination des ukrainiens qui ont su
repousser les forces russes et il a dit
conserver la capitale plutôt il est
aussi à les rouvrir l'ambassade du
canada lucas en ukraine il a après une
première tentative ratée il a réussi à
hisser le drapeau en haut d'un mât sur
le côté de l'ambassade vous savez il ya
une trentaine de pays qui avaient déjà
repris leur activité diplomatique depuis
plusieurs jours déjà plusieurs semaines
donc le canada a un peu tardé mais voilà
c'est fait les activités vont reprendre
monsieur trudeau dont qui est reparti ce
soir après une journée passée ici à kiev